today I'm going to show you exactly how
you can get people to open up to you
part two most of the time people just
won't talk about things that they've
been bottling up for months or even
years unless you prompt them to which is
why the second thing you have to do is
ask the right questions and not just any
question they're what I like to call
Assumption questions all it is is when
you make an assumption about someone
based on an observation and see if it's
true or not it shows that you are really
really listening because the only way
you can make an assumption like this is
if you are paying a hundred percent
close attention to what they were saying
how they were saying it and their body
language the second thing this does is
it causes them to react if your
assumption is wrong they will
instinctively want to correct you but
what I've found is that if you're really
paying attention you'll actually be able
to make a correct assumption most of the
time and when that happens when your
assumption is correct they will almost
always start opening up and that's how
you get someone to open up by reducing
your filter and asking assumption
questions follow us for more helpful
tips